the origin a and B and their our fixed
points okay and p is our moving point
it's going around such that AP by set I
should put it on your side AP by sex
this angle here i'm calling it BPO ok so
that's why I've got thinner and thinner
there because if you're bisecting angle
obviously both of the angles you end up
with i equal to each other okay now how
do you go about solving it because it's
got angles right it's something to do
with angles you can think of it purely
in terms of gradient and use like tan
inverse and I kind of thing I went down
that track and it started going really
bad fit so what I did instead was I
noticed that because we know where these
points are I know what this length is
namely it's one okay and I also know
what this length is which is too right
so seeing us theta and theater in these
triangles I can use the cosine rule ok I
can find out what these angles are equal
to it exactly in terms of what the other
three sides of the triangles are equal
to right so if you remember the way that
they are the way that the cosine rule
works if you're trying to find enabling
is cause of an angle is equal to a
squared plus B squared minus C squared
you can tell what the- is because that's
the one that's opposite the angle you're
looking at C and C so this C in this
case for instance if possible you this
left-hand triangle it would be the one
that's the angle sorry that's the side
that's opposite okay all over 2a be ok
now I'm going to use this to find out
what Opie and AP and BP are okay sorry
I'm going to use them to relate all of
those sides to the angles which is what
I'm after ok now just to spare your
sanity I'm not going to put down all the
lines of working that I've got here
because they do get quite involved but
hopefully I'll put down enough so you
can see what's going on
right so i use the cosine rule twice i
use it for apo and i use it for a pink
be okay so i get two expressions
eventually after some simplifying they
look like this it's expert yeah thanks
okay so there's the first one now if you
have a look at it let me see if I can
explain what's going on there's a
squared there's B squared and there c
squared okay cuz it's just one square
that's why it ends up as one now what
are these two this is the 2a be why they
gross square root don't tell me what it
look so awful it's just the distance
formula right thankfully it's from the
origin will be works super water from
the origin to XY that's what this like
this right and this is for the next
point of long okay alright that's fine
now when you're doing the other angle
which is a PB okay it follows much the
same structure except instead of going
from 0 0 I'm interested in this point
along the end okay so it's going to be a
little different looks like so Thanks
why this right yeah x minus 3
minus
ok now if you just think this was bad
just hold your breath okay now this is
what we had I think this is as far as we
got last time set right Evan this looks
familiar like we had this and we just
drop a hand really what am I supposed to
do with that okay which is not a bad
like I mean that's pretty ordinary thing
to say when you look at that however we
notice that on the denominator okay
we're going to have a few things in
common namely this 2 and this X minus 1
squared plus y squared appears in both
ok so I'm going to get some simplifying
going the question is how much right so
being the apo AP be they should be the
same so cosine of apo AP should be the
same right so this is the line that I
get I think after doing some canceling
I'm going to get this okay all of next
page
oops
okay so how do i get to this line here's
what i did up here and here you can
simplify them a little bit okay when you
simplify this top of cosine you'll get
this okay and when you simply this right
here this bottom one you get this
straight inside now what would you do at
this point if you had these two things
equal okay in some senses this is the
acquaintance of a lockerz it's just very
messy but what would you do to simplify
yeah you're eventually gonna have to in
either order it actually doesn't matter
which one you do number one you're gonna
have to square to get rid of the square
root site and number two you're going to
have to cross multiply because you've
got these fractures and they can't
really talk to each other because there
are different denominators okay so i'm
going to square everything and then i'm
going to cross multiply both in the same
line ok so just brace yourself all right
I had to I had to use a computer to
double check and make sure that I got
this right but you'll see why in a
second all right here we go take any
breath
now by the way as i'm writing this this
is one of the reasons why i would
suggest that you would never get a
question like this in actual exam and if
you remember anything about me telling
you what makes a good question and what
makes a bad question right what makes
this a bad question you tell me while
I'm still writing this you told me it
takes forever well that's true it's not
hard for my just for over from good
right so this question is very long it's
very time consuming but it's time
consuming for the wrong reason it's time
consuming because number one algebra
number two by the way like this is
actually the simplified result if you
actually wrote this down and you know
break out the factorization expanded it
would take you longer because you know
your mind will take longer than this so
another one it takes a long time number
two um it takes a long time to write
like a one-timer anyway so there you go
what do I done oh yeah that's true thank
you okay I've squared both sides okay to
get rid of the square root and then i
cross multiply now here's the thing at
first i thought this is just going to go
bad right like what game is there going
to be is it ever going to simplify and I
thought to myself after I got over the
initial shock of looking at this thing I
think it is going to simplify his wife
slightly after I square everything out
right think about what you know that
polar it was an nth degree right for
instance this top lightning in the left
hand side when you square X square plus
y square minus x squared Y squared one
sec okay it's degree to write for both x
and y so what was degree be after i
square it should be for Ray goes from
true up to four right and if it was 30 3
up to six now this is all going to be
force after i squared this is over to be
Jewish okay this will also be fours and
this will also be too so when you cross
multiply you actually see it here right
both sides will be in terms of two by
four is six ok and you can actually see
I need another color right can you see
that I've got one lot of Y squared here
and I'm going to get one lot of Y to the
four up here and I'll get exactly the
same thing over here right when you
cross multiply so I'll just have one lot
of weight of the six and that's not the
only term that's going to cancel okay
watch let's let's do it why do the six
cancel three x squared Y 4 cancels minus
8x 10 can cancel cancel now this is
interesting they don't all cancel then
all come out in the wash and that's
because the coefficients you've got here
a slightly different okay so just be
careful ah 3x that one cancels 16
cancels much for the coefficients this
way also doesn't cancel 28 here 31 here
minus 18 MOS 24 also doesn't cancel but
then let's see what do I got there 9y
squared there are did i write this down
I don't think ya never know there are no
9 x squared over here but then it starts
to collapse very quickly excellus 68 x
to the 5 22 24 9 right I think that's it
no yes double check yeah that's right ok
so after we get rid of all of the arm
the disaster Arthur mesh okay you end up
with I'm going to do two lines in one
okay number one i'm going to write get
rid of all of them things i can cancel
and number 2 i'm also going to collect
like terms because you can see I've got
six Y to the four here and I've got 914
here right so what would you do I guess
you'd take 6 over here and you get three
ok so I'm going to do both of those just
for the sake of board space and I'm
going to combine like terms ok so this
is what you